la conmoción continuó en Bolivia luego
de que se develará El Diario del difunto
sacerdote jesuita Alfonso pedrajas donde
confesaba haber abusado de por lo menos
84 menores durante su estadía en el país
dirigiendo escuelas para comunidades
marginadas al respecto la presidencia
boliviana informó que Se reserva el
derecho de admisión de nuevos religiosos
extranjeros y que envió una carta al
Vaticano con una petición al Papa
Francisco
que la justicia boliviana pueda acceder
a todos los archivos expedientes e
información referente a estas denuncias
y hechos de abuso sexuales cometidos por
sacerdotes y religiosos católicos en
territorio boliviano tras la difusión
del contenido del Diario de pedrajas la
justicia boliviana recibió al menos 8
denuncias por pederastia y algunas
víctimas se animan a querer contar su
caso
sólo pido justicia
porque nunca más se repitan agresiones y
hechos abominables
y estoy dispuesto y me lo juego todo
algunos preguntan Y por qué ahora y por
qué yo respondo le digo sabes qué
preguntas lastiman
salen sobrando porque no sabes el
calvario que hemos vivido durante la
última semana Se realizaron
allanamientos en algunas escuelas
incluyendo el tradicional san Calixto y
la curia provincial en La Paz El
objetivo del gobierno boliviano está
definido esclarecer los hechos y
encontrar justicia